Thếm nhiên, Mới Lâm Tội, đi trên cao tốc, hà nội bắt dàng được cảnh sát sào thông
công an tính bắt ninh phát hiện, biểu về với gia đình. Trong lúc làm những vụ,
trên cao tốc, cảnh sát sào thông công an tính bắt ninh phát hiện một thiếu
niên đi bộ trên làm dừng khẩn cấp theo hướng hà nội lạng sơn. Qua sách mình được lượng
chức năng sách mình cho bé bị cầm điếp bẩm sinh niên không thể giấu tiếp.
Tổ định nhiều phát hiện thảo, cho dân xe xuống hiểm rào tôi, hỏi đi tạo không biết nói,
đừng trả đi cũng phục không phục xây xếp. Tình áo của cháo để có hí xuất hiện khoải để at đi
hạp luôn bố cháo. Theo người thân, chưa mới bắt thức bẩy, cháo tự đi bộ dời khỏi nhà,
đến tối không phải còn trở về gia đình đã tổ chức tìm kiếm và chính máo công an.
Tạo đây, người dụng đặc đi tìm kiếm, hả mất lịch, nói, để đi đi tự xác thông của gặp
bác, nói, tự xác thông của gặp bác, nói, tự xác bác, nói, đối gặp bác,